[Music]
a big inspiration for me with the games
we're building at branches I want to
enable
more 15 year old Daytons to be able to
build whatever they want and monetize it
and nobody gets in their way
[Music]
branches building blockchain based nft
games with a focus on mass adoption I
started this company because when I was
14 all I wanted to do was play Minecraft
and be on Skype calls with my friends
all day and so I wanted to build a
platform that kind of smashed those two
things together High School is a waste
of time and I also grew up in the middle
of nowhere and I didn't really fit in
there I was kind of like the only person
who was into computers at all so I'd get
bullied a lot at school so I tend to
just stay at home stay in my room play
on the computer and I just found that it
was a lot more productive and I could
build things so 16 I dropped out and
all I knew was that I wanted to make
games I was working on Minecraft servers
at the time and you know there was a lot
of competition there was a lot of other
people making Minecraft servers and I
got sick of competing and I wanted to
make something that I could just sell to
all these people that they could all use
and something that was lacking was you
didn't know who your player base was on
your server
so you couldn't tell you know how many
people were coming on a day when they
were coming back any of those metrics so
I built kind of like the first Google
analytics or mix panel for Minecraft
servers and just started selling it as a
subscription and I sold that company
when I was 17. and with that I got a
plane ticket and I moved out of Missouri
and went to California because I was I
was done with it
[Music]
our first collection the raft has about
a thousand Ethan volume which at today's
rates is a little over 1.3 million and
each raft is trading for about 14 eighth
or roughly twenty thousand dollars we've
raised 15 million today and it was very
difficult in the beginning because I
didn't know anybody right and I got
lucky I got an invite to this app called
Clubhouse and I started going in there
and talking to a lot of people who were
deep in the tech and just started
telling them about my business and what
I was working on and people got really
excited about it I ended up raising our
first Angel round
just through that
and
you know from there it kind of
snowballed I remember it took like a a
good month or two to get the first
commit and then after that the rest of
the round came together in like 24 hours
the second time we fundraised was a
little more difficult
so you want to talk about grit and
resilience we were kind of going through
this cycle where we saw a lot of users
come in right we had like three million
people join our game within like a month
and then a month later they all left
and within that window we'd gotten a
term sheet and had it pulled away
because our metrics were falling and at
that moment we had like a month of
payroll left
and we didn't know what we were going to
do and I told everyone that and they
were like yeah you're probably going to
shut the company down not many people
make it back from that
and it was two weeks later that I pulled
it together and just
had I had no other choice to right so I
pulled it together and we ended up
raising double what the term sheet was
originally for
I want to be known for creating a
platform that enables more people to
take the path I took but a lot easier
getting into games learning to code at
an early age and monetizing that was
very fortunate for me it helped me
escape a lot of things and if I can help
other people do that but make it a lot
easier to learn to code a lot easier to
make games and a lot easier to monetize
them then more people will be able to
take that path and I think if I can do
that for a lot of people then I would
have left a good Mark on the world
foreign